[Musique]
oui mais une apparente à celle ci s'est
mise à mal cette semaine c'est clair que
j'en avais parlé du projet visionnant un
projet d'extraction pétrolière qui
parlent pour lui cosson les côtes de
terre-neuve et labrador
bien sûr j'aurais envie de parler de
plein d'enjeu les enjeux les justement
d'extraction hautement les enjeux liés
au gaz à effet de serre toute discussion
autour même de l'histoire qui lie à 10
peu trop leurs affaires au canada auquel
pétrole va tout ça bien sûr c'est des
sujets que j'aimerais beaucoup discuté
mais que je sais qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes qui ont beaucoup
plus qualifiés que pour en parler mais
un enjeu que j'aimerais vraiment
discuter c'est un des rares points
positifs qui avait dans la présentation
je demande avait dit non c'était en lien
avec l'approbation par les communautés
autochtones des projets ça fait partie
maintenant l'évaluation des projets
pétroliers mais pas juste et projets epr
et animer les projets énergétiques et
autres qui se passe au canada bien sûr
pourquoi c'est positif pour moi bien non
pas que je dis jamais sans nous
écouter nous et bien là on est écouté
mais bien sûr c'est pas toujours facile
ni parfums justement de réintégrer la
parole d'un pan complet de la population
quand ça a été oublié ou négligé pendant
des décennies pourquoi est ce que j'ai
encore une raison de shiori c'est que
dans les dernières années même les deux
dernières années ont vraiment clairement
aidé à mettre en lumière grâce justement
la mobilisation est souhaitée non
seulement amener
dangereux tokten l'avant mais a vraiment
vraiment éclairci légalisé par rapport
au fait qu'au canada on encore une idée
du bloc monolithique autochtone donc les
autochtones comme un grand groupe qui se
tiennent par la main qui chante comme
barrick sont d'accord ou pas d'accord
van sant alors que ce n'est pas le cas
et je pense que la venue des projets
pétroliers comme ceux ci les projets
d'extraction où on veut dire qu'il faut
avoir l'approbation des communautés
autochtones vont devenir des anges sens
je me sens beaucoup sur mon expérience
personnelle parce que nous on ne la
communauté eu tout le projet de la
romaine donc
l'approbation de la communauté à cette
époque le sait quand même pas si loin le
ces 2009 c'était eux ce timbre
clair parce que pour avoir l'approbation
des communautés autochtones faut avoir
un appel à une probation libre et que
leyritz assistons demande de la part des
pays pour pouvoir continuer de l'avant
on a eu l'approbation des communautés
mais c'est que souvent cette approbation
libre et éclairé viennent il faut même
sous la contrainte se défend de
contraintes systémique qui sont imposés
par le canada qui sont placés là depuis
quand même très longtemps moi je pense
beaucoup parce qu'on n'est pas touche en
sus d'une communauté à l'autre d'avoir
un conseil de bande qui est soit bien
représentée qui les briques et l écoute
de sa communauté comme toutes les villes
sont pas représentés par des maires qui
ont à coeur je te mangerais bien leur
population versus le bien l'économie en
a d'autres que c'est au professeur a
aussitôt fait des rêves donc vous
comprendrez que on a les mêmes changé
dans nos communautés liées à nos élus et
avec mitsou et peine on a pu le voir
parce qu'on avait quand même les groupes
traditionnels avec des formes de
leadership rationnelle qui se posaient à
des décisions qui avaient été demandées
prises par les chefs des réserves et on
sait que la loi sur les indiens c'est
une loi qui s'applique sur les réserves
et non sur les territoires dits en sait
trop
cependant comme le canada est grand et
comme nous sommes une entité sont
multiples il y a il reste des
leaderships traditionnels qui sont
mélangés quand il dort chef de bande il
ya des leaderships rating complètement
disparu dont qui va le refaire surface
parce qu'ils ont été et à une force
parlement donc vous pouvez imaginer un
peu partout au canada dans les
communautés autochtones qui lie à des
débats sociales politiques
même religieux il faut garder ça en tête
alors avec business que je vois ce que
je veux mettre en lumière met un gros
phares dessus c'est qu'on va dire qu'il
ya eu consultation des communautés
autochtones et ça ça va être très
important pour l'avenir c'est est ce que
c'est un conçu une consultation qui est
libre éclairé puis libre ça veut souvent
dire aussi est ce que quand on a
consulté la communauté on avait une
communauté qui était pas sous la loi sur
les indiens sous un conseil de banque et
des fois peut être dirigée d'une façon
où on désavantage certain membres la
communauté on en avantage d'eau une
autre chose aussi c'est que libre et
éclairé c'est que des fois on va se
faire un tel projet va être fait telle
chose doit être fait pour réparer le
projet mais on ne parle pas aussi qu'est
ce qui va se passer si il ya des restes
écologique si justement on fait des
emplois pour les communautés autochtones
mais ces employés ça va toujours rester
des sous-emploi versus les bons membres
qui vont être employés dans les
communautés petits enjeux ne sont pas
toujours discuter profondément et on n'a
pas pu tout à en avoir a priori
justement tout les éléments est clair
donc je dis ça parce que je regarde
aller ce qui va représenter la
consultation des communautés autochtones
est ce que c'est une consultation café
croissants ou est-ce que les gens
viennent nous voir disent bonjour amené
croissance est ressortie disons de
consulter les communautés autochtones ou
est ce que la voix de tous les membres
des communautés parce qu'il faut se rend
compte qu'elle communauté autochtone
selon leurs structures politiques selon
leurs droits ancestraux ne répondrons
pas de la même manière aux mêmes enjeux
et ils ne répondront pas non plus même
structure donc ça va être très
intéressant parce que ça va nous sortir
de cette ère monolithique de l'identité
autochtone verts justement une
reconnaissance des enjeux très typique à
chaque nation sur son territoire selon
les enjeux d'extraction ou
d'installation de barrages hydro
électriques ou d'éoliennes ou de tout ce
qui peut venir s'installer
bien sûr faudra pas non plus négliger
que des personnes autochtones qui sont
membres des communautés mais qui ne sont
pas sur la communauté qu'ils ont
travaillé pour leur communauté en dehors
des milieux urbains et il peut y avoir
des personnes qui vont travailler pour
l'industrie sont autochtone au japon des
personnes autochtones sur les
communautés qui vont vouloir ça parce
que qu'est-ce que tu fais après des
décennies de pauvreté de
sous-financement
du management des fois même des fonds
qui sont envoyées pour pouvoir installer
des projets sur la communauté des fois
ça va des discussions comme ça et là ces
discussions là vont se faire sur la
place publique avec bien sûr le
commentaire extérieur des fois de
personnes qui n'ont pas nos enjeux
particulièrement à coeur donc tout ça va
devenir une discussion future parce que
maintenant qu'on fait partie de la
discussion publique maintenant qu'on
fait partie de la communauté de la
société vraiment d'une façon beaucoup
moins visibles ça va devenir une
discussion inévitable à avoir et des
enjeux qui ont inévitablement à gérer
des fois avec des gens qui ont des
opinions mais aucun aucun enjeu réel
dans la question et d'autres personnes
qui vivent ça au jour le jour qui voit
justement les impacts des changements
climatiques directement dans leur
communauté dans leur sécurité
alimentaire
est ce ça va être vraiment discuté aussi
pour eux et des fois sans eux alors vous
pouvez imaginer que ça devient très
intéressant on garde l'oeil ouvert sur
ces enjeux là qu'on veut essayer des
demis trimer pour pardonner en même
temps la parole ou communauté qu'on n'a
pas été mise sous silence alors choix
d'une baisse a même îles du ponant
rééducation et n'hésitez pas non plus à
partager ses vidéos parce qu'elles
servent vraiment à déconstruire des fois
des mythes et ça va avoir des
discussions qui sert justement à tisser
le le tissu social qu'on essaie de créer
aujourd'hui en 2010 alors juste une
belle semaine